we were so incredibly poor that I never
ate like a fresh piece of fruit
I do remember struggling you know
fighting with my brother over a banana
because that was the one banana we got
for Christmas I had traumatic
experiences in the country I came from
three two one go I remember afraid
everything I came here I was 29 years
old I'm not but my daughters were baby
when we moved here we experienced the
explosion so at the very first explosion
in my area when week later I was hit in
LA my mom immigrated to America about
two years before me and my brother did
so for those two years I didn't see her
I didn't really hear from her I was
small enough to at one point forget my
own mom like I knew I had a mom but I
didn't remember
you know her specifically and so that
was really traumatic she immigrated from
Bulgaria that's my home country and we
were so incredibly poor that I never ate
like a fresh piece of fruit I do
remember struggling you know fighting
with my brother over a banana that was
the one banana we got for Christmas I
feel welcome in America 3 2 1 go
I feel fully welcome in this country and
I realize I have I harbor privileges as
a white person an educated person but
the same can't be said for you know
people of color people who have
emigrated and still have their accents
such as my mom my mom still has a strong
accent has been told to go back to her
home country has been told by employers
that you know she's a little bit to this
that at the workplace and so I strongly
agree but my mom probably wouldn't LA
gave me a roof that no one else give it
to me even though with my broken English
and with my accent
I got opportunity to work and the
highest department stores all I felt is
welcomed and loved when I came here with
my parents and the 90s from Kosovo you
know we were agree to basically with
open arms we had a kind of like a foster
family kind of situation where they took
us in they gave us a guest room and we
lived there for a few months until we
got on our feet today I like I I feel
welcomed here I don't feel out of place
my family has felt pressure to
assimilate 3 2 1 go
so every time we were home we spoke
Cambodian as much as possible but
feeling they need to simulate what my
parents had went through and they didn't
know who to trust even their own people
so when they came here they were just
telling me hey stay in your lane do what
you're supposed to do be as I guess you
want to say American as possible so it
was tough to really separate the two and
I felt like I had to be American so when
I talk to my friends you know if I say
hey you know my beanie and I'm from here
they ask me like you know what are words
you can say in all being and how's your
culture like and they were always very
interested in what you know where I come
from you know my culture and so that's
why I never really felt like very
pressured to be like completely American
I felt like I could always kind of have
a bit of both I have a lot of
responsibility of being American right
now because for the past seven years
I've been just proving myself and
achieving and learning the language and
now the responsibility is so big I'm not
on the Sirian I'm also American I got my
citizenship this year and
and just it's responsibility to pay back
what I took from this country my people
that came over all wanted to assimilate
they all wanted to have the Thanksgiving
turkey which is you know for
Thanksgiving but we also have the rice
and beans with it do you feel like the
assimilation happened naturally or was
there pressure no I think it happened
totally naturally it was like let's be
thankful that we're here and that this
great country is giving us everything
I support the immigration policies of
President Donald Trump three three two
one go I think there's got to be a
reason that when we come here that we
come to make the country better and not
take from the country and I think that
he wants to make sure that everybody who
comes across the border
is people that we know my dad is 75
years old well-known doctor back home in
Syria he visit America five times with
zero intention to live here and take
advantage of the country at 2017 since
the Trump ban they canceled his visa and
now I cannot see my dad I think the ban
on serious because of what the turmoil
that's going on in Syria right now is is
the problem I don't agree with building
a wall and I don't agree with separating
children from their families under the
guise of saving the children it's just
it's really sickening
and I don't agree with it at all
refugees of all cultures are accepted
equally in the United States three two
one go
a lot of American they have fears from
us and they don't know what happened or
the struggles we went through we're
talking today about LA but in other
states they have like a huge like red
flag about the refugees in Miami when we
arrived it said no dogs no Cubans but I
also think that there's a fear of some
refugees when you don't know what
they're coming for and what type of
refugee is today's refugees that you see
on television are somewhat different
they're trying to say that illegal
immigrants are refugees and I think that
that's where we start having problems
you can't compare someone coming from El
Salvador or Guatemala or Nicaragua who
are not going to be killed like we were
if we didn't leave we are really
refugees because of where we were forced
to leave or we would have died my partly
agree with what you're saying that the
difference but they're still trying to
escape like how we did when we were
younger and they just wired a better
life and I think that's something we
should think of when we think of either
both immigrant or refugee not everyone
is entitled to come to a host country
three two one go
I guess real agree but I think real
degree because we are refugees and we
had to come in the right way you know I
don't think everybody should should be
allowed in I think it should be because
you want to come in and assimilate and
be part of the American dream
I agree with you there's has to be a
program like me after six months I got
my papers
I was working paying taxes going back to
school my kids were in the school so we
were good to this country you know what
I mean we didn't mess around America is
for everybody I got it but it has to at
like a test one-year program this is for
me because you don't know everybody I
think I didn't understand the question
yeah what was the question again why if
a human being is suffering in their home
country I believe that as human beings
they have the right to seek a better
life for themselves maybe even if it's
through illegal means these people are
looking for better lives for themselves
and for their kids just like we all are
I think that what is happening today a
lot of the people that are coming into
our country aren't here to be Americans
or produce better for America they're
here to take out them to see what they
can take I've experienced it from both
ends I served in the US Army so I'm
familiar with a lot of american-born
individuals who take advantage of that
system but they're not immigrants
they're not refugees when we vilify them
that's when I think there's issues
showing empathy and showing even
sympathy that's something I want to
express if I have children I would want
them to grow up feeling truly American 3
2 1 go
I have three daughters 15 12 and 10 they
love it here and they don't have an
accent they don't have any issue and
also they speak fluently Arabic at home
because my mom doesn't speak English I
want them to take the best of our Syrian
culture and also the best of being
American I want them to have Bulgarian
roots I want them to speak the language
I've also lived in Australia and the
more that I grow up I actually don't
feel like I'm missing a home I feel like
I have three different homes Australia
America Bulgaria and I just feel richer
and I want that same advantage for my
children thank you
[Music]
[Applause]